(inspirational music)
(bike gears whizzing)
- BMX is a fast-paced sport.
From the time that that gate drops,
until you cross the finish line,
you are always thinking
about your next move.
As long as I can keep those
two wheels on the ground,
I'm gonna be out there on that track.
(subtle piano music)
My name is Kittie Weston-Knauer,
and I am 70 years old.
I am the oldest female BMX racer
in the United States.
I have been involved in
the sport of BMX racing
as a racer for 30 years now.
And I love challenges.
And this was just another challenge.
When I began racing BMX,
there was no women's cruiser class.
I worked with our sanctioning bodies
and talked about the fact that
women want to be a part of this.
We now have thousands of women and girls
who race throughout the country.
♪ And the rockets red glare ♪
- [Announcer] Here we
go, 56 and over women.
Seventy years young, Miss Kittie Weston-Knauer,
sitting in that three slot.
More total points for her.
(gate crashes)
- [Girl] Go, Miss Kittie!
- Throughout each year, I will do
anywhere from 25 to 30 races.
And quite often, I'm racing
much, much younger women.
I’ve finished seventh in the world
in the 45 and over women's cruiser class.
I was the oldest female
to participate in the UCI BMX Worlds.
It's just unbelievable.
This can be a dangerous sport.
In 1993, I was involved
in an accident where,
after falling off of my
bike, I broke my neck.
I was told that I might not
be able to walk again.
But within six months,
I was back to racing.
And I have continued to
be involved in the sport.
- Miss Kittie.
Morning, Miss Kittie!
(cheering)
- Thank you, thank you.
Good ride.
You know, people have asked me:
How long do I plan to
keep racing BMX bikes?
I tell people, age is nothing but a number.
And I seriously mean that.
Every time I get out on that track, I win.
- You got this, Miss Kittie.
- And it's not about crossing
first, second, or third,
but it's about having fun.
It's about the enjoyment
of being with others
who really enjoy this sport.
(gentle music)
I want to continue to enjoy life.
And this is a part of my life.
(gentle music)